y
[Música]
esta canción habla sobre todas las fotos
personales que publican en internet
sobre ustedes mismos sobre sus seres
queridos
sobre todo lo que ustedes son y sueñan
con ser
[Música]
todos los días dejamos rastros digitales
cuando navegamos por internet cuando
intercambiamos información o cuando nos
desplazamos pero hasta los datos más
inofensivos nos exponen a múltiples
riesgos
no hay que olvidar que su modelo
económico es recolectar la mayor
cantidad de información posible para
después venderla a los que quieran
encontrarte exactamente a ti
la manera de protegerse no va a ser la
misma si el riesgo es porque uno tiene
un marido celoso o una esposa celosa por
el jefe en el trabajo o como en mi caso
porque trabajo con wikileaks en
documentos de la enee sea y de la cia
esta es una advertencia muy seria para
el resto del mundo nuestras libertades
civiles se están desvaneciendo ante
nuestros ojos
jóvenes alumnos ciudadanos comunes y
corrientes periodistas disidentes todos
tenemos niveles específicos de riesgo
digital pero existen soluciones entonces
cómo podemos aprender a protegernos cada
uno desde nuestra propia escala
algunas personas dicen que la privacidad
ha muerto pero yo no estoy de acuerdo
es totalmente falsa hay muchas maneras
de protegerse incluso en nuestro mundo
hiperconectado y con mucha vigilancia
estatal
[Música]
y
mccomb es es un actor y músico que vive
en berlín es un gran usuario de las
redes sociales y de los servicios que
ofrecen los gigantes digitales
hace poco tomó conciencia del rastreo de
sus datos mack sabe que en la alemania
de hoy para él los riesgos son limitados
pero se preocupa por la creciente
amenaza que representa los gafas para
nuestras libertades
para aprender a proteger su vida privada
asiste al caos communication camp cada 4
años este evento reúne una comunidad de
hackers y aficionados al código
provenientes de toda europa que vienen a
compartir y construir un internet más
abierto
[Música]
y me alegra verte a mí también tengo
algunas preguntas para ti wang píxel de
mis grandes objetivos que nunca
usted es deshacerme digamos pero google
de lo que aconsejamos para google es
compartimentar las actualidades utilizas
una de sus aplicaciones porque no puedes
evitarlo y al menos puedes tratar de no
utilizar todas sus aplicaciones para no
revelarles toda tu vida
por lo general
recomiendo diversificar las herramientas
que se utilizan por ejemplo en vez de
depender de google para los correos los
mapas las búsquedas las traducciones se
pueden utilizar herramientas que
respetan nuestra vida privada y que
responden a todas nuestras necesidades
lo que más recomiendo es empezar por las
aplicaciones en las que no se depende de
nadie como por ejemplo el navegador en
vez de utilizar google chrome se puede
usar firefox se puede usar chromium o el
navegador thor hay muchas alternativas
y una vez que se haya encontrado un
nuevo navegador por qué no probar un
nuevo motor de búsqueda se puede
utilizar top top go por ejemplo y hay
otros algunas personas utilizan si es o
cuánto existen muchos motores de
búsqueda que respetan nuestra vida
privada
[Música]
esta tarde estamos hablando sobre
facebook todo el mundo quiere salirse
pero nadie lo hace
en realidad no sabemos que podría
reemplazar a facebook
y como sociedad nos resulta difícil
entender que en qué derechos y a qué
libertades renunciamos al utilizar
facebook o facebook si mi teoría es que
deberíamos tener el control de los
algoritmos de nuestros datos saber
exactamente cuáles son recolectados y
que ocurre con ellos
y eso no es posible con el pueblo
económico actual de facebook si viste la
oposición contra la instalación de
google en el barrio que es ver que en
berlín has oído hablar de eso se generó
mucha conciencia sobre la manera en la
que google se infiltra en nuestras vidas
si fue increíble hasta para google
google creo que nunca se habrían
imaginado una oposición así
en 2018 tuvo él tuvo que renunciar a un
gran proyecto del campus tecnológico en
cruise ver ante la presión en las calles
creo que berlín es una ciudad bastante
libre
los berlineses dejaron claro a través de
las manifestaciones y la presión
política que en croze berg quería una
base de análisis
[Música]
como la mayoría de los artistas max
necesita las redes sociales para
promocionar su trabajo pero cada vez se
sienten menos cómodos
esta mañana tiene una reunión con
miembros del reclaim cloud culture este
colectivo agrupa a actores de la vida
nocturna berlinesa que quieren
organizarse de manera independiente
cap sufridos cantar
hubo muchos escándalos sobre el uso de
los datos personales y la vigilancia de
los usuarios nuestra idea es lanzar una
gran campaña invitada a los clubes y a
toda la escena cultural berlinesa para
que elijamos juntos una alternativa
donde sea posible publicar los eventos
antes
investigamos encontramos un proyecto en
desarrollo que se llama móvil y son
qué funcionaría como una alternativa
para facebook y benson
yo suelo estar en contacto con artistas
y músicos y estoy seguro de que en una
ciudad como berlín
hay una oferta cultural única ese sería
un muy buen punto de partida para lanzar
la iniciativa y luego exportarla a otras
ciudades
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoy en día la protección de la vida
privada nos concierne a todos en
particular a los adolescentes grandes
consumidores de redes sociales como
instagram snap chat king tic toc
en casablanca los profesores del liceo
francés louis mazinho decidieron
mostrarle a sus alumnos la cara oculta
de sus aplicaciones preferidas
buenos días
hoy vamos a trabajar sobre las redes
sociales que algunos de ustedes han
leído las condiciones de uso de una red
social
bueno yo honestamente nunca las he leído
porque tienen palabras muy complicadas y
son realmente largas así que nunca me he
tomado el tiempo de leerlas y también
pienso que si todo el mundo las acepta
pues yo también quiero aceptarlas una
abogada inglesa se escribió estas
condiciones en un lenguaje muy accesible
para los jóvenes incluso a partir de los
9 años
entonces aunque sea responsable de las
informaciones que publicas en instagram
nosotros podemos guardar utilizar y
compartir las informaciones personales
con empresas conectadas con instagram no
somos responsables de lo que harán estas
otras empresas con tus informaciones
además de los datos que ustedes publican
también ingresan algo que se llama
metadatos a la piel de la hora a la que
se conectaron cuántas veces se dieron me
gusta algún contenido etcétera ellos le
venden ese conjunto de datos a unas
empresas que a su vez pueden re
venderlos a otras empresas
vamos a pasar ahora al segundo fragmento
y después podrías leerlo por favor
oficialmente eres dueño de las fotos y
vídeos que públicas pero estamos
autorizados a utilizarlos también
podemos dejar que otras personas los
utilicen en cualquier parte del mundo
otros pueden pagarnos por el uso de esas
fotos y videos pero nosotros no
tendremos no tendremos que pagarte por
eso fácil
es realmente impresionante es como si
nosotros les diéramos como si les
diéramos la madera hiciéramos el fuego
pero no sintiéramos el calor exactamente
así es pero por otro lado ellos te
dieron la chimenea puedes utilizar
instagram en totalmente pero los datos
les pertenecen a ellos y los van a usar
siempre es así se puso cansado
[Música]
la vida privada de los alumnos es muy
importante para nosotros porque si
nosotros no protegemos la vida privada
de nuestros alumnos quién lo hará en
realidad se exponen a tres tipos de
riesgo en cuanto al uso de sus datos
principalmente existe la explotación de
los datos por parte de los gafas o por
las empresas asociadas con esas grandes
empresas
también está el riesgo de que sus datos
sean utilizados por hackers que hayan
obtenido un control sobre su cuenta o
sobre el acceso a ella y después por
supuesto hasta el riesgo del uso de
datos entre alumnos para hacer
ciberacoso u otras cosas
el ciberacoso en las redes sociales es
una problemática que afecta a muchos
jóvenes para tratar de prevenir este
fenómeno los profesores enseñan a sus
alumnos cómo proteger mejor sus cuentas
recuerden que durante la clase anterior
jugamos a buscar las fallas en la cuenta
de un compañero de un amigo puedo oír
algunos comentarios al respecto
yo personalmente hice la prueba con
richard y su cuenta de instagram y su
cuenta de instagram es privada pero
tiene su nombre y en su biografía está
su edad y en su foto de perfil aparece
su cara y no tiene publicaciones
pero tiene historias en las que se puede
ver a donde viaja y cuando viaja
muy bien y entonces consideras que su
cuenta es como está bien ahí bien se
puede mejorar no bueno pero yo tampoco
soy el mejor ejemplo
si uno se toma el tiempo de sentarse y
mirar todos los parámetros de
confidencialidad encontrará verdaderas
joyas por ejemplo es posible decidir
quién ve las publicaciones por defecto
puede estar predeterminado para que sea
público pero uno puede cambiarlo para
que solo las personas que uno ha
aceptado en su página puedan verlas
entonces es posible decidir qué usuarios
tienen acceso a la información personal
aquí dice permitir que los motores de
búsqueda externos enlacen a tu perfil si
o no y por defecto está predeterminado
que si entonces es aquí donde realmente
se pueden configurar las opciones que
son importantes para uno
un chico
no
hola señor me azul mi nombre es wey que
soy una investigadora de hong kong he
seguido su trabajo sobre seguridad
digital
me gustaría que pudiéramos reunirnos
para hablarles sobre la situación que
vivimos en china
confía en su discreción
he sido lo más cuidadosa posible pero
aún así tengo miedo
al igual que miles de habitantes de hong
kong way que no pensaba correr ningún
riesgo en línea
pero la revolución de los paraguas el
movimiento de resistencia contra china
lo cambió todo ahora los servicios
chinos pueden vigilar las comunicaciones
de todos los ciudadanos de hong kong
entonces cuenten cómo es la situación en
hong kong
no hace más que empeorar
la policía es cada vez más violenta y ya
no hay posibilidad de diálogo
todos estamos muy preocupados
ok si usted tiene algún tipo de plan
lo primero que quisiera hacer es
aprender a protegerme en internet
y después podría ayudar a otras personas
la idea es lanzar una campaña de
sensibilización para el público general
y me preguntaba si usted conoce algunas
personas que me pueden aconsejar
[Música]
he vivido en china y conozco muy bien
las prácticas del gobierno chino se como
espían a la población como logran
localizar a ciertas personas me preocupa
que algún día pase lo mismo en punto
para que las personas puedan seguir
trabajando en la defensa de nuestro
estado de derecho
y de nuestra libertad de expresión es
realmente necesario que aprendan a
protegerse
de mazatlán auto detectan shows
[Música]
halo hola soy wake
dígame a qué se dedica
trabajó como investigadora pero después
de la insurrección
me involucré en formaciones de seguridad
y organizó campañas de información y de
prevención con personas que tienen un
alto nivel de riesgo
y quiere aprender un poco más sobre el
modelado de amenazas
si el modelado de amenazas es algo nuevo
para mí
ok eso ayudará a determinar su nivel de
riesgo hay que hacerse cinco preguntas
primera pregunta qué información quiere
mantener privada
el modelado de amenazas es un
procedimiento para pensar de quién hay
que protegerse qué datos hay que
proteger cuál sería el peor escenario
posible
permite entender cosas como bueno
ellos son mis adversarios de que son
capaces puede interceptar mis
comunicaciones
pueden obtener datos de mi proveedor de
internet pueden piratear mis datos
y visitar a mis adversarios son los
servicios de inteligencia del estado
tienen recursos financieros y poder
tecnológico
creo que mi mayor riesgo sería poner en
peligro mis contactos es lo que más muy
preocupado con el peor escenario para mí
sería ser arrestada
me interrogarían y en el peor de los
casos me torturar y en
esas son cosas comunes en china
amén
[Música]
la vigilancia internet se ha convertido
en un gran problema para los periodistas
al contactarlos sus fuentes corren el
riesgo de dejar rastro en línea que
después podrían servir para
identificarlos y perseguirlos para
enfrentar esta problemática
julian assange que fundó en 2016
wikileaks
esta plataforma segura permite que los
informantes envíen documentos sensibles
manteniendo su anonimato
en particular wikileaks dio a conocer al
público general los abusos cometidos por
el ejército estadounidense en irak y
afganistán
puede ser ese de ahí de ventanas a los
lados es una furgoneta penitenciaria
pero no sé si viene hacia aquí podría
ser él
convertido en blanco del gobierno
estadounidense desde 2011 julian assange
está amenazado con ser extraditado a
eeuu donde enfrenta 175 años de cárcel
[Aplausos]
el primer contacto con una fuente se ha
convertido en un verdadero problema para
nosotros los periodistas
imaginemos por ejemplo si usted es un
informante y que tiene una información
importante que quiere compartir conmigo
y me escribe por ejemplo desde un correo
de gmail que tiene su nombre y que usa
desde hace años o si me llama desde su
celular ese intercambio dejará un rastro
digital permanente entre usted y yo yo
propongo diferentes niveles de seguridad
hacia alguien que no corre ningún riesgo
al contarme puede hacerlo por twitter
por facebook por correo y ya está
alguien que eventualmente podría tener
problemas y sabe que me contactó puedo
hacerlo a través de signar y una persona
con un modelado de amenaza muy alto por
lo general alguien que trabaja o que
trabaja para un servicio de inteligencia
que quiere revelar me un documento puede
hacerlo a través de secure drop un
programa que se creó precisamente para
poder contactar a un periodista de
investigación de manera anónima y segura
[Música]
en 2010 yo era reportero para 10 pig él
en londres y estaba con los del new york
times' y los de the gardian en una
especie de búnker del guardián
y juntos redactamos los primeros
reportes sobre la guerra en afganistán
y resulta muy sorprendente ver todo lo
que escribíamos en esa época en simples
correos electrónicos
y wikileaks de manera un poco molesta y
repetitiva
nos pedía constantemente que ciframos
todo y que fuéramos más prudentes
y nosotros nos reíamos de eso de esos
paranoicos tipo ajá
pero trabajamos juntos fue una verdadera
colaboración periodística y ahora me
pregunto que hice de diferente en esa
época en comparación con julian assange
es más
al leer con atención la orden de
extradición de eeuu surge la pregunta
quiénes son los próximos en la lista
quiero decir que hicimos nosotros de
diferente
[Aplausos]
al tener documentos que pueden ser
comprometedores y que son de interés
público pero que no saben muy bien cómo
manejar lo primero que hay que hacer
ahora es identificar al interlocutor
correcto identificar al periodista que
sea capaz de hacer público un documento
minimizando al máximo el riesgo
lo que yo recomiendo por lo general es
comprar un nuevo computador portátil
barato una pequeña tablet o algo por el
estilo
ir a un café donde haya una red wifi
pública
descargar el navegador thor y conectarse
a la página de sectur drop así es
posible contactarnos
enviarnos un mensaje y luego se puede
pasar a la etapa siguiente y ver cuál
sería la mejor manera de recibir la
información sin comprometer la seguridad
de nadie
[Música]
ah
por su parte max explora la pista de
mobileye son la alternativa para
facebook events que pronto debe salir a
la luz hoy junto con otros artistas se
reúne con los desarrolladores de
mobileye song para hablar sobre el
funcionamiento de la plataforma
entonces en nuestro caso como artistas
que hace que todos sigamos en facebook
todavía
desde hace 15 años estamos acostumbrados
a confiarle y delegarle todo a facebook
de almacenamiento de los datos el
mantenimiento de los servidores si
ustedes quieren crear una instancia de
móvil y son deben almacenarla en alguna
parte y deben pagar por el
almacenamiento del servidor pero ese es
el precio de la libertad'
esos son los costos que facebook y los
demás nos ocultan y los recuperan
robándonos nuestra vida privada
ok sienten nivel eso quiere decir que
podemos tener nuestro propio servidor
local eso que tú llamas una instancia
después ahí se instaló el programa
se le da un nombre como móvil ais berlín
y podríamos invitar a los artistas y los
clubes de berlín para que vayan a
nuestra plataforma
y podrían comunicarse con los usuarios
de otros servidores de alemania y del
mundo entero es así
sí exactamente ese es el modelo federado
es nuevo paradigma
[Música]
la plataforma federada más conocida es
la red social más todo desde su creación
en 2016 varios millones de usuarios han
decidido emigrar desde twitter hacia
esta alternativa libre
[Música]
la palabra federación significa que no
hay una única autoridad que controla
toda la red sino múltiples autoridades
por ejemplo el sistema de los correos
electrónicos también es una red federada
hay servidores
gmail uno se registra en algún servidor
y obtiene una dirección de correo
electrónico que empieza con el nombre de
usuario y termina con el servidor que se
está utilizando
ese sistema permite que uno pueda
enviarle un correo a cualquier persona
en cualquier servidor solo usando esas
direcciones de correo la federación es
un sistema que permite repartir las
autoridades a diferencia por ejemplo de
twitter o facebook donde digamos que hay
un solo servidor y millones de usuarios
mastodon al estar descentralizado hay
muchos pequeños servidores
cada servidor le pertenece a una persona
oa una organización que lo administra y
permite que los usuarios interactúen con
cualquiera que también esté en cualquier
otro servidor
para preparar el lanzamiento de la
plataforma móvil iphone max invitó a sus
amigos artistas a una script ovario
durante esta velada informal los
neófitos pueden descubrir alternativas
para la gafa y aprender sobre las bases
de la seguridad en línea
[Música]
vamos a hablar sobre navegación sabe lo
que es una vpn perdón una bp en una red
privada virtual no
muchas personas protegen su vida privada
conectándose a una vpn para luego entrar
a internet desde esa bpn
la ventaja es que su dirección ip
pareciera venir de la vpn y no de su red
personal
y eso protege en parte su identidad
ya ha oído hablar de torno y conoce la
diferencia con una vpn
no realmente no ok esto es el acrónimo
de the onion water es el router cebolla
en es similar a una vpn porque su
conexión a internet parece venir desde
otro lugar
pero contorno hay sólo una protección
hay 3
porque pasa tres direcciones ip
diferentes antes de conectarse a
internet
y gracias a todas esas capas sucesivas
razón por la que se le llama romper
cebolla su conexión a internet en teoría
es anónima por supuesto deja de serlo si
usted después se conecta a facebook
en la mesa de al lado se concentran en
la de utilización de los celulares
android existen alternativas para la
mayoría de las aplicaciones
por ejemplo google maps puede ser
reemplazado por open street map o por
one maps para evitar compartir la
geolocalización en google
lo que no entiendo bien es que cuando
tengo un celular android y una cuenta en
google a todo mi celular está conectado
a google así que de todas maneras tienen
acceso a mis datos
efectivamente dejar de enviarle datos a
google requiere una operación más
compleja
hay que reemplazar todo el sistema
operativo android por un sistema
operativo como línea libre y de código
abierto
por lo general el movimiento script o
parís recomienda el software libre y de
código abierto lo conoce puede repetirlo
libre y de código abierto libre y de
código abierto libre y de código abierto
básicamente nos pertenece a todos el
código abierto está disponible para que
todo el mundo pueda tomarlo utilizarlo
modificarlo compartirlo con otras
personas no se puede ser más
transparente
en francés yo explico el software libre
con estas tres palabras
libertad igualdad fraternidad
porque esa es exactamente la idea del
software libre
libertad significa que cada usuario es
libre de utilizar el programa
igualdad porque cada usuario tiene los
mismos derechos
y fraternidad porque fomentamos la
cooperación entre los usuarios
una de las prácticas maliciosas más
comunes es el espionaje de los usuarios
hay que partir del principio de que
cualquier programa que no sea libre
envía sus datos personales y su
actividad en línea a otras empresas y
quizás algún estado
[Música]
en los últimos años el mundo de la
educación ha iniciado una gran
transición digital en casablanca el
liceo francés louis mazinho emprendió la
aventura en 2017 el equipo de profesores
tuvo que escoger entre distintas
soluciones incluyendo las propuestas de
los gafas su telón de fondo era la
pregunta por la recolección de los datos
de los alumnos
probamos 5 o 6 soluciones en el
establecimiento había varias algunas de
pago otras de código abierto y así
pudimos ver bien los pros y los contras
de cada una
por supuesto los gigantes digitales nos
propusieron soluciones inmediatas
prácticas concisas integradas
ergonómicas simpáticas agradables sin
embargo lo que dio nuestra decisión y la
de todos los profesores fue la libertad
pedagógica pero lo que ofrecían esos
gigantes digitales eran soluciones llave
en mano y una solución llave en mano
suele ser restrictiva
en términos del respeto de la vida
privada y de los datos que son
recolectados nos parecía adecuado el
software libre y además siempre hemos
tratado de privilegiar las soluciones
del código abierto más que las
soluciones patentadas
onenote una solución de microsoft
también fue una de las propuestas en ese
marco pero resultó que no estaba
adaptada para el contexto escolar y en
el caso de google chrome rápidamente nos
dimos cuenta de que tendríamos que
utilizar el sistema de mensajería y el
chat de google para asegurar su
funcionamiento
eso obligaba a asignarle a cada alumno
una dirección de correo electrónico
algo que no es recomendable para los
alumnos de secundaria
primaria y por eso los profesores
rechazaron esa opción
[Música]
finalmente el equipo escogió la
plataforma moodle y el sistema big blue
puro
una alternativa azul pero inicialmente
no fue una decisión unánime porque el
software libre tiene la reputación de
ser más complicado de usar
[Música]
al principio mudo él es poco atractivo
no es muy intuitivo y tampoco es muy
agradable a la vista pero en realidad
permite que los profesores sean hiper
creativos se puede hacer cualquier cosa
es modulable al infinito
[Música]
y otros
en londres comienza el juicio de
extradición de julian assange en la
cárcel de alta seguridad de belmarsh las
cinco semanas de audiencia lejos de las
cámaras fueron precedidas por la jueza
vanessa para ser
eeuu pide la extradición del señor
assange por la publicación ilegal de
documentos confidenciales sobre las
guerras en afganistán y en irak esta
publicación habría podido poner en
peligro la vida de informantes que
trabajan para eeuu
el enjuiciamiento de un periodista por
publicar documentos confidenciales es
una primicia histórica en occidente la
profesión se preocupa por el precedente
jurídico que esto podría sentar
cómo funciona wikileaks lo que pasa es
que se firma un acuerdo de
confidencialidad con lo cual se respeta
el embargo se respetan los protocolos de
seguridad la comunicación se hace a
través de sistemas de mensajería seguros
y luego se accede de manera muy segura
también al documento e idealmente se
utiliza de ellos el de jls es un sistema
operativo extraíble puede estar en una
usb o en una tarjeta sd se reinicia el
computador con tails y entonces todas
las comunicaciones se hacen a través de
todo es un computador que no está
vinculado a mi entidad entonces eso
permite tener un nivel de anonimato
adicional
cuando el nivel de riesgo es demasiado
alto generalmente se trata de trabajar
de manera desconectada
eso significa que se utilizan
computadores que nunca han estado y
nunca estarán conectados a internet y en
esas máquinas desconectadas solo se
abrirán ciertos documentos cifrados en
las oficinas de internet en nueva york'
se construyó incluso un espacio
asegurado y aislado una especie de
alcatraz con placas de metal en las
paredes para bloquear cualquier señal
proveniente del exterior
[Música]
desde 2020 hay una nueva ley china
específica para los opositores hong kong
en ses ante esta amenaza ahora wake in
realiza talleres para los activistas
sobre las normas de la seguridad en
línea
muchas gracias por haber venido
hoy vamos a hablar un poco acerca de
seguridad pero antes de empezar me
gustaría hablar sobre la ley de la
seguridad nacional quienes si ustedes
han oído hablar de esta nueva ley
en la práctica apenas alguien deja de
gustarle el gobierno por cualquier
motivo pueden enviar esa persona china
para que sea juzgada por un tribunal
chino
[Música]
entonces por eso nosotros también
debemos reforzar nuestras medidas de
seguridad lo realmente importante es que
si frank sus comunicaciones en
particular sus correos electrónicos
claro también se trata de sus compañeros
si los atrapan también atraparán a sus
amigos he hablado con otros activistas
que conozco y ellos ni siquiera saben lo
que significa cifrar es aterrador
si envío un mensaje por internet desde
este computador lo puedo enviar sin
cifrar
y cualquiera que esté en el camino mi
red de wifi me roiter mi proveedor de
internet o cualquier otro
todos esos intermediarios eventualmente
lo pueden leer
pero si lo cifró con pgp nadie puede
leerlo con tanta facilidad
se utilizan dos llaves
dos números
la primera simplemente va a esconder el
mensaje que quiero enviar como cuando
arrugó este papel así para entenderlo
mejor
entonces cuando lo envío los
intermediarios no pueden hacer nada más
que transmitirlo
y cuando la otra persona lo recibe tiene
la llave secreta el otro número para
descifrarlo
esa segunda llave es como un abrelatas y
eso es lo que debemos aprender a hacer
en la sociedad civil las personas suelen
tener conocimientos tecnológicos
limitados
y se enfrentan a unos adversarios que
tienen muchos medios para acceder a los
dispositivos
e interceptar las comunicaciones
así que en esos casos hay que dejar de
lado esos aspectos estrictos sobre su
movilidad digital y pensar más bien en
términos de seguridad operacional
la seguridad operacional consiste sobre
todo en cambiar el comportamiento
individual para minimizar los riesgos
[Música]
cuando se creó internet era la promesa
de un nuevo espacio de libertad pero
ahora está más que todo controlado por
grandes empresas y estados para
preservar nuestra vida privada estamos
obligados a aprender a protegernos por
nuestra propia cuenta
el problema es que ninguna fuerza
política importante ha podido proponer a
que podría parecerse a internet si no
estuviera en manos de empresas con tan
poca imaginación que solo piensan en
vender publicidad la manera en la que se
ha organizado el conjunto del sistema es
una locura no fuimos capaces de imaginar
estructuras que pudieran tener una
política económica diferente en la que
los datos puedan ser propiedad de los
ciudadanos y no de las empresas que nos
ofrecen la infraestructura a mi parecer
ese es el tipo de preguntas que deberían
formar parte del debate sin ambiente
ahora toda la atención se centra en
bruselas la unión europea es la
institución que más se ha esforzado por
poner orden en el lejano oeste de los
datos personales
[Música]
si unimos nuestras fuerzas a nivel
europeo con los estados miembros
realmente podremos establecer un nuevo
estándar global el reglamento general de
protección de datos que regula el
seguimiento de los usuarios
especialmente a través de las cookies ya
marcó un cambio histórico a nivel
internacional pero en última instancia
pienso que tendremos que desmantelar las
grandes empresas antes de llegar a eso
por supuesto hay otras soluciones
desarrollar la competencia y fomentar
que las empresas conviertan la
protección de datos en el punto fuerte
de sus modelos económicos
[Música]
podríamos imaginar otros servicios
financiados y desarrollados para
respetar la vida privada con un modelo
económico diferente ya están emergiendo
algunos en el marco de iniciativas
locales el problema es que se necesita
una dinámica detrás de todo esto se
necesitan recursos hay que invertir
miles de millones de euros en estos
servicios y para ser capaces de inyectar
miles de millones de euros hay que tener
otras prioridades políticas a nivel
nacional y europeo
[Música]
es el día d para max y sus compañeros
después de dos años de preparación lanza
en su plataforma independiente móvil ais
punto berlín ahora conectada con otros
miles de plataformas suman un ladrillo
más al edificio del internet libre
[Música]
hoy estamos aquí para celebrar a
movilizar y lanzar la página web por eso
los invitamos aquí esta es la dirección
de la plataforma está en línea tiene
funciones geniales y están conectadas al
fe diverso que es el futuro de las redes
sociales del código abierto libres y
descentralizadas eso es todo regístrese
[Aplausos]
y
en el fondo hay que pensar de dónde
viene nuestra libertad si bien díaz
somos libres es solo porque en el pasado
algunas personas aceptaron hacer
verdaderos sacrificios por su libertad
no necesitamos que miles o millones de
personas se conviertan en héroes o
corren riesgos enormes sólo necesitamos
que miles tal vez millones de personas
acepten tener unos pequeños
inconvenientes
liniers
lo único que cuenta es nuestra capacidad
de decir no si de vez en cuando decimos
no no voy a hacer esto porque
significaría renunciar una parte de mi
libertad haremos avanzar la lucha para
reconquistar nuestra libertad en el
espacio digital
abdomen
[Aplausos]
ah
acogemos a otra flor
salvación
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esto
[Música]
pasa
t